alzheimer's and brain awareness month
50 000 nevadans are living with
alzheimer's disease right now two-thirds
are women joining me this morning two
ladies who are very familiar with this
cause katie windmill megan french ladies
you guys are hoping to make a change
with your fundraiser coming up this
saturday or this sunday love conquers
alls and it's part of the longest day
event which uh folks at home if you've
been paying attention to the campaign it
is the longest day which is summer the
21st and basically you can kind of do
whatever activity you want all day long
to raise money for alzheimer's but this
is how you guys are doing it now first
before we get into the event itself the
connection and the cause
a hitch at home yeah katie you have a
very special connection with this what
got you involved with alzheimer's
association so my grandma passed away
from dementia in 2019
growing up my grandma was just really my
rock in my life she
taught me a lot of things growing up and
i she took care of me
as she progressed in her disease those
roles completely switched
i had to take care of her and then
as she got worse i had to teach her how
to re learn how to eat and how to
get up in the morning and all those
things my sisters my mom and i were
really ultimately her caregiver and
it's really hard to see someone you love
forget who you are
alzheimer's is just that disease that
you watch someone
you love
like you grieve their loss while they're
alive and then
while they pass away you grieve it all
over again so
as caregivers you are just really
watching that person
fade away so that's what really led us
to
create this event and create um you know
this amazing cause and helped people
that suffered through the pain and we
were just seeing some photos of you and
your grandmother there and you're so
young to have already taken on this huge
undertaking that so many caregivers at
home probably understand exactly what
that's like
megan the event itself is coming up on
sunday let's let's jump in how can folks
help what are you guys doing absolutely
so as heather mentioned the longest day
is like what we call your diy fundraiser
so katie did her first triathlon last
year and so as this is an event that you
do something for an extended period of
time she decided to ride her stationary
bike for 10 hours
we'll see
but while that's going on we
started sharing about this event with
friends and i own a small business
called french press and so i wanted to
donate a percentage of sales
and then it just grew so we'll be at the
gray room
people can join us for we have yoga
going on at 8am
we have a pop-up market with resources
as well as
vendors that you can shop from noon to
four
dr kinney who is the head of unlv center
for brain health will be speaking at 11
30.
and then we're going to have a final
watch party with some dinner and a
champagne toast from five to seven
excellent it's really exciting to bring
everybody together there is so much
going on and folks at home here take a
look at your screen this is the event
information that megan just ran through
everybody is invited anyone can be there
go support katie 10
hours but support alzheimer's you just
never know who's going to be diagnosed
and we need to find a cure for this
horrible debilitating disease and the
many people that it impacts ladies thank
you so much for being on the show this
morning good luck on this wonderful
event you're gonna be great you've got
this 10 hours a drop in the bucket right
yeah
it's a good one um and of course we're
going to put more information on our
website eightnewsnow.com if you have any
questions